you're a stand-up person ellen degeneres
you spread so much love and cheer you
might as well be Santa Claus suddenly
you're 12 days of Christmas special
makes perfect sense but every so often
you push your guests a little too hard
and things get super uncomfortable to
say the least
most of the celebrities who appear on
The Ellen Show are cool calm and
collected but somewhere so awkward they
had us hiding our heads inside of our
shirts hug a pillow for support because
things are about to get cringy Katy
Perry back in 2017 Katy Perry
guest-starred on The Ellen Show and
Ellen chose to play a game called will
you parry me
Katy wasn't a big fan of the game
claiming that she didn't want to get
married again and Ellen pointed out that
Katy had never been married before which
wasn't true this made for a super
awkward TV moment
Katie had to remind Ellen about the time
that she was married to Russell Brand
Jake Gyllenhaal Ellen is hilarious but
she has a reputation for putting her
guests in the hot seat without warning
and that's what happened to Jake
Gyllenhaal when he guest-starred on The
Ellen Show in the spring of 2019 Ellen
called Jake out asking him why he didn't
follow her on Instagram and the actor
insisted that he did when in reality he
didn't the look on Jake's face says it
all Taylor Swift back in 2013 Ellen
wouldn't stop accusing Taylor of dating
Zac Efron but it didn't end there
Ellen invented a game designed to make
Taylor reveal everyone she had dated and
wrote a song about it and it was so
personal Taylor refused to play but
Ellen didn't get the hint she went on to
play the game herself
and by the end of it she had Taylor
questioning her way of life Justin
Bieber Justin Bieber had appeared on The
Ellen Show a handful of times but in
2015 and we blew up a picture of Justin
in his birthday suit while on vacation
in Bora Bora
Justin was immediately embarrassed when
he saw the picture on the screen but
Ellen wasn't finished yet she pointed
out that there was a mystery female in
his room which made Justin super uneasy
Nicole Kidman in the spring of 2017
Ellen welcomed both Nicole Kidman and
Yatta De Laurentiis on her show she
oughta taught Ellen and Nicole how to
cook some signature dishes and it didn't
take long for Nicole and Giada to bump
heads
Nicole rolled her eyes at Giada and
scolded her for not having a timer and
just when things couldn't get any more
awkward she insulted her cooking's I'm
just gonna look down here and touch that
Dakota Johnson well the fact that this
is a newsworthy event in in our in our
world right now is pretty Chaka Khan to
me he's got super uncomfortable on The
Ellen Show when Ellen pointed out that
Dakota hadn't invited her to her
birthday for two years in a row good as
it turns out Ellen just didn't remember
getting the invite then when talking
about TIG Notaro Dakota revealed that
she was her favorite comedian and
immediately took it back it was so
awkward Dakota pretended to walk off the
stage jessica simpson but no celebrity
interview was harder to watch than
Jessica Simpson's she talked about her
daughter's birthday and how she hired
fake mermaids to swim in her pool but
the star took things too far when she
talked about the mermaids being carried
away to go to the bathroom because they
couldn't go on her children Caitlyn
Jenner in 2015 Ellen asked Caitlyn
Jenner how she felt about people of the
same gender getting married and Caitlyn
had some very backward views this was
pretty awkward considering that Ellen
herself is married to a woman despite
everything Caitlyn stands for she still
seemed iffy about people of the LGTBQ
community tying the knot and Ellen was
clearly upset about it but I said what
do I do about that he said nothing you
can't do anything about it
kanye west kanye west is a man of many
words and he made that obvious when he
guest-starred on The Ellen Show in 2016
Kanye went on a 6-minute ramp while on
the talk show and Ellen was at a loss
for words
literally
we wouldn't be surprised if that was
Kanye's last time on The Ellen Show
Nancy but the most Awkward Ellen moment
of all time didn't involve a celebrity
but instead a secret camera that caught
an audience member taking two souvenirs
instead of one Ellen called Nancy out in
front of the entire crowd and put her in
Ellen jail for the rest of the show
Ellen's actions were so uncalled for it
left audience members feeling super
uncomfortable especially when Ellen made
a comment suggesting that Nancy wasn't a
good person all this because Nancy took
an extra gift for her sister who
couldn't make it to the show
if you love staying up to date with the
latest celebrity news hit that subscribe
button here at the things we post daily
videos that are sure to keep you
entertained so turn on notifications to
stay in the loop if you're watching on
your phone go into your YouTube settings
and switch on notifications so you never
miss another video we hope these awkward
Ellen moments didn't make you too
uncomfortable before you go tell us
which one of these guest star
appearances made you cringe the most in
the comments section below thank you for
watching the things don't forget to give
this video a big thumbs up we'll see you
again soon
[Music]
you